- Do you work out with Faith?
Does she work out?
- She works out, yeah.
And you know--
- [Kelly] 'Cause she always looks so good.
- Uh, she's pretty hot.
- [Kelly] I know!
(audience laughs)
I know.
- As the kids have grown up
and as the kids have gotten older
we find that we're gettin'
to spend a little bit more time together
in the gym downstairs.
So I'm enjoying that for sure.
- That's so cool, all right.
I also was reading your pre-interview
and I didn't know that you love to cook.
You and Faith cook.
- I love to cook.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We both cook.
Faith's a fantastic cook.
I mean--
- Yeah, I bet.
- She can cook anything, and--
- She does everything great, Tim.
- She does everything great.
- She's beautiful.
- Yeah, I know.
- Yeah.
- I know,
she married way below.
- [Kelly] Whatever, whatever.
- But uh, yeah, she's a great cook.
I do the staples.
I mean we cook some healthy,
well a lot of healthy stuff,
but we cook some stuff that's
not so healthy as well.
I mean chicken and
dumplings is a big go to
at our house.
- Yeah, it's southern.
- That's sort of how I hooked Faith
was with chicken and dumplings.
- What, how do you mean you sort of--
- I took 'em to her house,
we were touring together.
I didn't know her that well
and she lived right down the road from me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I made some chicken and dumplings
and I thought you know, I'll
take some chicken and dumplings
and some cornbread down to Faith Hill
and see how that
works out.
- I just wanna be a fly on,
it worked. (laughs)
I wanna be a fly on
- I still cook 'em
every now and then to see
if it still works. (laughs)
- You're like, you still love me, right?
It's like, (laughs)
- I just can't imagine being
her just opening her door
and Tim McGraw standing there
in chicken and dumplings.